well the Trump administration failed to
get Congress to throw out Obamacare man
now it's turning to the courts and legal
papers filed yesterday the Justice
Department argues for the first time
that the entire Affordable Care Act is
unconstitutional
Paula Rida to the White House with a big
shift that could put millions of
Americans health coverage at risk Paula
good morning good morning a big shift
indeed and a move to try to deliver on a
signature Trump campaign promise to
repeal and replace Obamacare the Trump
Justice Department now says that it
agrees with a lower court ruling out of
Texas that declared all of Obamacare
invalid that December ruling came a year
after the GOP tax bill repealed Obama
cares tax penalty for people who are
uninsured new Texas judge ruled the
provision was so central to the law that
it just couldn't stand without it and at
the time the Trump administration argued
that some parts of Obamacare would stand
including an expansion of Medicaid -
statement yesterday House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi said the Trump administration is
declaring a quote all-out war on the
health care of the American people the
White House has said it does expect this
case could reach the Supreme Court which
is upheld Obamacare twice John
Paula thank you a very important story